you
all right thank you everybody for coming
out my name's Adam like oh no I work at
tumblr I used to do digital signal
processing stuff I was electrical
engineer for a long time and then I
stopped I work with big data because
it's cooler now and uh and so we're good
so I came to this realization that it's
pretty easy to combine these two things
relatively speaking and so I wanted to
start doing this pause and give a talk
so I'm really excited to be talking
about this and so what I'm going to talk
about mostly is signals and filters I
suit does anybody here has already done
digital signal processing stuff before
okay who knows what a Hamming windows
okay so handy well I I wasn't trying to
get a gauge so I'm assuming that people
don't know anything about signal
processing which is awesome seems like
most of you will get some pallets um so
I'm going to talk about sampling which
is how you go from representing a signal
in the analog world to the digital world
you have recorded or you calculate it or
something what that means the frequency
domain
two main classes of digital filters or
filters in general deserve they're
called finite impulse response and
infinite impulse response and I'll say F
IR and ir and then we'll get into
scalding scalding is what we're going to
be using to actually implement this type
of stuff at scale and Duke this is not a
talk about scalding but i'll just give
you enough syntax that we can move along
and then we're going to apply it we're
going to filter 140 million signals and
then we're going to see what that looks
like with tumblr blogs so Perry minute
doesn't know anything about tumblr we're
blogging platform there's 140 plus
million blogs that we host it's free to
sign up it's fun to use the big signals
that we have we've got a social graph
that works similar to like Twitter or
Instagram things like that as opposed to
facebook linkedin where its direction on
graph i can follow your blog i can like
things i can recall stuff from its of a
pair of mine
um you don't have to follow it back in
order for that to work so we'll be
working with that social graph a little
bit later and so this is a signal is say
daily users on a website you've got two
main components you've got a sort of
trend like a seasonal effect maybe maybe
your websites more popular during
football season or something and then so
that's the big thing the smaller one is
a weekly variation so that that simulate
see in there is seven days repeat to
peak anybody that works or website has
probably seen something like that before
which she believes tumblr on saturdays
and sunday it's different week if you
work first business software and it
probably gives it more during the week
and so the key component here to think
about is that this is awesome a general
signal and the main things are that
they're evenly spaced measurements time
wats right it's one day exactly between
each of these and that's crucial to
power that that consistent spacing
there's no missing data
you know we're missing a day you have to
infer it somehow or put a zero in there
or something so you need a complete time
series the other thing is that there are
two signals here right there's the one
one that has a large amplitude and a low
frequency that's the trend the other one
has a smaller amplitude or higher
frequency that's the weekly variation so
we can think of these signals as being
sums above pure sine waves with
different amplitudes or phases I'm not
gonna talk about phase but that's an
important thing in the real world and so
we can generate this signal or by
combining all these pure sine waves or
we can take this signal and break it up
into all of its different pure sine wave
see the amplitude of each and so that
pulling these things apart is a crucial
element so if you have this website and
you know you know you of his weekly
variation it's not interesting so you
run a seven day moving average right I
think that everybody does it takes you
know today is Wednesday so take from
last thursday until today count the
number of apt abusers average them and
that's the output for today this is
something that every business analyst
has probably done at some point this is
the simplest digital filter and so we'll
talk more about how to generalize this
in the bottom and so these are some of
the words that I'm going to be saying a
lot signal I've already said a ton of
times right it's just a series time
series of data when I was doing a
generic stuff this would be their holds
or current or something like that now I
deal with things like posts and
impressions and follows it's different
but can be treated the same sampling
period is the time between all of these
samples so before was one day you know
if you're working with audio frequency
it's the same thing period when sampling
frequency which is the inverse of CES 44
children's right 44,000 samples per
second and the reason that they chose
that there's this thing called the
Nyquist frequency none of the highest
frequency that you're able to represent
digitally so human ear can pick up
roughly 20 hertz to 20 kilohertz so if
on a CD you want to represent that
highest frequency that here the means
that the CD has to be sampling these
actual like audio like the waves coming
out of my mouth has to be sampling those
somewhere higher than 40 kilohertz
otherwise bad things happen um and so
I'll show that a little bit later as
well ah and so that's all sort of
sampling in time series or time domain
stuff on the filter on the frequency
side we've got filters right a filter
this is like a Wikipedia definition then
I have to make it less clear I think but
I think we all know what a filter is
right
you want to you know get rid of noise in
something or you want to remove your
weekly trip things like that right
you'll have a bunch of frequencies going
in and you want to make sure some get
through maybe amplify them and we want
to make sure it's some don't there are
other types of filters as well piece of
ones that were working on the stop band
and the pass band are the sections of
frequencies that you want to either
block from getting through or allows you
go through the cutoff frequency is the
sort of dividing point there and so to
think about signals I think this is a
pretty cool picture smoke signals
because they are kind of a digital
signal right it's not this continuous
thing that's growing up people are
deciding when to a min of slope thing or
whatever um so it goes back really far I
would have to find something about like
smoke signal communications and how it
might be like related to digital
communications but couldn't find
anything so this was dancing looks like
right we've got an analog signal on the
left and it's a sine wave right we've
all seen sine waves before and when
we're working with it digitally we need
to actually look at it and make a
measurement right and so I'm making ten
measurements for every period with a
sine wave and I don't know what the
original thing actually looked like all
i know is that beat this red line that
I've drawn is what I have to work with
so it looks pretty good like you might
be able to see on the topic it's like
Browns a little bit higher the red ones
flat but we can pretty clearly see that
this is the thing that we're working
with however I sampled at one period one
sample
period you have no idea right it's the
same height every single time you sample
so when you're working with this on a
computer programming which we all do
you're getting a flat line right here
there's no variation in your users or
whatever it's completely useless and if
you do two samples which I said is in
the you have to have at least two
samples in order to represent this
frequency you can see the things going
up and down at the right rate but like
it looks like a zigzag where it's really
not a zigzag there's a lot of missing
fidelity so when working with digital
signals you really have to be aware of
what frequencies are there and if you
have to do some sanity checking on are
the numbers in my program however what
I'm actually physically work enough it's
less of a concern when i'm working at
like website scale because things don't
change faster than we can write them
down really but if you're going from
some sort of analog signal to digital's
is very very important and so the next
thing part is builders
I I really like this analogy of a coffee
filter if you think about what a coffee
filter does right it takes two inputs
dry ground coffee beans and hot clear
water and it blocks some of it and it
lets some of it through and what comes
out is hot black coffee at the end right
and it if you think of a filter what you
want to let one thing through a block
another if this is a perfect filter in
that sense you would put these things in
and you would get hot water on the
bottom and ground coffee beans dry in
the filter so real signal filters work
in the same sort of way where you're
able to block most of it right most of
the crimes are still in your coffee
filter but enough one through to turn
this into delicious beverage and
likewise you know most of the water made
it through but the crimes are still
going to be wet so if if these are you
to sort of frequency bands we stopping
in your past band you're going to be
able to block most of it I'm not quite
all of it and so
if we've got a focus of filter like this
right and free signals are often viewed
as just passing through the filter
continuously you can do this in real
time you can do this morning good batch
mode but the idea is an all these block
diagrams are drawn yes I'm signal goes
into a black box it is a filter and then
you have some other signal coming out
and so we're going to go through we're
going to take this input and we're going
to turn it into that output by filtering
it ah and so the first thing we need to
do is we need to decide where's our past
man wears their stop band right so this
is in the x-axis here is frequency right
first or something and so the Nyquist
frequency at the end is the highest
represented sample that's why it's at
the end so that in this case is going to
be 500 points because that's just the
same time period I chose and so we want
to let that the low frequency trend go
through and we want to stop everything
else but like I was saying earlier it's
not going to be perfect it's gonna be
more like this where you're not going to
be able to fully reject everything below
the cutoff and fully above the cutoff
rather fully accept everything in the
past band so kind of people
but it won't be bad and so I talked
about filters we haven't talked about
how to like actually when it is actually
made out of how you actually apply at
things like that we saw the moving
average earlier in the beginning and
this is what you're doing right you are
taking some input X you're multiplying
the current value and the previous six
in total seven values multiplied to come
by one seventh add them all up that's
your weekly average and then you
increment tea tomorrow and you do the
same thing again it's pretty simple you
can you know there's a function of our
filter that will do this for you of fi
are digital filters bathe he's mad but
instead of having one seventh for all of
your values you have to choose this list
of coefficients so you have up to n
coefficients you do the same thing you
multiply today's value by the first one
and so on add them all off thats your
filter output and choosing these
coefficients will make it either you
know they decide what the cutoff
frequency is that is beside if you're
going to let high or low frequencies
pass through and block the other all of
that comes down to deciding these few
coefficients so all the machinery is
exactly the same for most types of all
these class of filters we just need to
figure out what to actually put in there
and there's the power function filter
you give it an input value of a vector X
and you give it a filter vector H and it
gives you the output which is nice so
before we actually apply it we need to
think about but this looks like in the
frequency domain so this is noisy signal
is something that I made in our it's not
really noise per se it's just a sum of
three different frequencies the lowest
one is one-half perks of the frequency
in green as a Neptune of one you can
clearly see that and then the other
stuff you can clearly see unless you
zoom in there's 250 Hertz signal and 400
and those have smaller attitudes so my
coming out concerning are so if you
split this apart use the Fourier
transform I'm not going to speak too
much about this before you transform but
it's basically just an operation that
will take this input split it into as
many frequencies as we can possibly
represent in continuous time it would be
an infinite number of frequencies but
we're working in discrete time digital
things like that so it's somewhere
between zero and 500 you can see there's
a huge spike near zero that's the one
half there's a slightly smaller supply
cut 250 an even smaller one to four
hundred so this is what we've got going
in we know that so we want to filter out
the two higher frequencies we want to
get rid of the 250 we want to get rid of
the 400 so to do it you go to a website
because other people have built all of
these tools and they're free and their
online you can do the math lab has an
amazing signal processing
don't really need it for simple stuff
like this so I went to his website and
the numbers are talking on my screen so
in this loss here I said between 0 and
250 the signal to pass through or 200
Hertz rather I want the signal to pass
through and from 250 to a full 500 I
want it to block as much as possible and
this is called a bode plot and this is
on a log scale on the ripples and things
like that are sort of unavoidable those
aren't just but they're very far down 40
DB is is a pretty significant squashing
for a signal like this but you really
just going to go in and say this is what
I want this is what I don't want and it
gives you that box over there on the
right and those numbers are the filter
coefficients that's H and so you can
fiddle around with like the pieces want
to keep the pieces you want to get rid
of and it will just keep updating those
numbers for you when you're done you
grab them put them in your program and
you're good to go so I did that and the
this value of eight it gave me 21
numbers that's them on the bottom and I
use the filter function and are to send
that noisy signal through and this is
what I got out what smells so clean you
can see 400 is completely squashed I
don't know if you can see there's a tiny
little blip at 250 Hertz that's what
ended up making sure that's why I made
sure that I put the cutoff right now
where we have
so you can see that and so that's the
idea right you you're constantly just
doing essentially a weighted sum of the
most recent values you've seen coming in
from your signal and you it's a it seems
to me like it's a pretty simple thing
but it's extremely powerful the other
class of filters that I mentioned are
called infinite impulse response and so
this is the difference between two one
on the left is what we've seen before
finite impulse response the one on the
right is that plus another piece and
that other piece is a new set of
coefficients which I called G and
instead of multiplying previous inputs
were multiplying previous outputs of the
filter and so I'll explain why it's
called infinite but it's applied there a
lot more powerful and also anything with
the word infinite in it you should be
queria infinity is a really bad place to
be so you they can be more powerful in
the sense that like the transition
between your staff and pass band can be
much sharper but it could hurt you in a
way so I keep saying impulse response
this is wouldn't do pulse response is
before I show why one it's called finite
and one is called infinite this is a
delta function queers heard of a delta
impulse function things like that good
it has the value zero everywhere except
at time zero has the value one in
continuous time it would have the value
infinity but fortunately we don't have
to do open to the best time so what
we're going to do is we're going to take
this signal then we're going to send it
through our filter and it sounds kind of
boring because it's just one point but
what you do is you get a you get a good
picture of what this filter is made out
of right like what it looks like you got
a good snapshot of it so I did that for
two filters one on the left is our seven
day moving average it's a simple example
to work through on j0 it has a value of
one so the average is 17 on day one the
input is 0 but the previous day was one
so I valued 17 and so on so it just
traces out for seven days that's a value
and then after that it's gone everything
that this impulse could give to the
system has been used in thrown away in a
finite amount of time the one on the
right is infinite impulse response so
the idea is that on day one you take
your input take half of it in this case
and that's the other on day two you take
the previous output one half take half
of that so quarter is your output and so
on right so that initial one point
impulse actually it approaches you're
awesome tonically but it's always there
right according to a mathematician I'm
an engineer i would say that at point 10
it's completely gone but that's fine but
the thing you have to be careful about
is what happens if i said that value
instead of one
21.1 well this is called positive
feedback every day you're going to take
the previous output make it bigger take
the previous up but make it bigger this
is really bad it's I don't think any
filter design tool you ever use will
give this to you as a result but if for
some reason you messed up this would I
mean I've destroyed electrical
components and things like that by
trying to Jack voltages up higher than
they really should so the last picture
of Independence response is this is the
one that I designed in this tool it's
got this nice pretty symmetric shape to
it does anybody recognize that shape
it's a sinc function the sinc function
is the Fourier transform of a box
function which was something that takes
the value of zero everywhere except from
say negative one to one is the value one
or any width right symmetric around zero
taking the Fourier transform that will
give you this so it's just sort of
inside but
most filters that you design will be
symmetric like this and things like that
moving averages are kind of like a hack
but you know they're a very very special
case but they're ones that I think
everybody understands that's why I'm
using them ah and so quick recap on F IR
filter specifically before we move on to
other stuff you're really just weighing
you know we're taking a wait of some of
your previous and inputs like a moving
average in order to actually use this
and apply any two things you need if
you're doing in real time you would need
the previous end inputs X and you would
also need this filter coefficient around
if you're doing it in batch you would
obviously have the whole vector input X
which is what we're going to do next so
a tumbler we're starting to scalding a
lot more it's 12 by Twitter it's
excellent this is their logo I guess so
it's a domain-specific language it's
written in Scala and it's sort of a
wraparound cascading and cascading is
yet another sort of workflow language
that makes it easier to write MapReduce
jobs usually on the Duke you can run
them locally if you've just got a whole
bunch of data on your disk that won't
fit in RAM
but it's really nice for it with solving
is similar to pink which gives you Pig a
lot of people say it's similar to hive
but on the skin it's really not at all
like high five is like my sequel but
into Duke pate is more like a few have
to explain my sequel step by step that's
what you would tell ah it feels like
real programming I don't know who it's
over here use Arm python pretty much
yeah so it's been a while since I've
worked with like compilers and type
system and things like that I felt great
I don't know it feels good to get back
into it um and so we're building a lot
of libraries internally in this like
we've got stuff to load all of our data
sets and make sure that you know
everything's formatted correctly and
whatnot and any corrupt daters thrown
away we've built my base classifiers
some statistical tests and things like
that that are really fun to run at scale
meaning terabytes of data so slightly
less general overview of sculling um if
anybody's used plier or Kenda's it's got
this split applied by paradigm you take
a data frame or a table or whatever in
this case they call it pipe split it up
into groups apply something to each
group and then put them all back
together to each of these pipes is
essentially doing
has one or more columns we called fields
and you can easily apply row wires
called computations so adding two things
in the same row maybe you make a new
field at the as a result use math that
if you want to do a few lies operation
meaning like say you want to get the
ever so you want to get the average
number of posts / blog or something like
that or the total number of posts / blog
you group by the blog ID and then you
perform a function on that group which
is the knockout function so here's a
quick little hello world what the actual
syntax looks like there's not a ton of
overhead if you use Java a lot there's a
lot of overhead interviews Python a lot
but it's really not that bad so we've
got a method of class actually called
blog posts it will go and grab all of
our tumblr post activity data who posted
it where they're from a little bit about
the content what type of post it is what
we've got a type to post a system be a
photo or audio or link or text or
whatever
so we get some information about that
and what we're doing here is we're going
to group by the blog ID and we're just
going to count the size of that group
that'll give us how many posts that work
for each blog and then from there we're
going to call that post count and there
we take that post count send it to this
other little anonymous function that
takes this pc in thing that will return
a boolean saying whether or not they've
posted less than 50 times and then
filtering out and this is not the
filtering in the sense we're just
talking this is just like do I keep this
row or not so it looks like what we're
doing here is a sort of reverse way of
saying give me all the blogs that posted
at least 50 times keep only the fields
called blog ID and post count and then
write it to a tap separate file
somewhere right it's you know this is
basically in hive or sequel this would
be like select blog ID count star group
i blog ID and i guess in pandas are
applier it was the sort of similar to
this but this is the idea and you can do
there's so much going on here behind the
scenes there's a lot a lot that you can
do I'm not going to get into it a whole
lot here there are some really good
resources their wiki is pretty well
documented for what they cover in the
wiki Edwin Chen who used to work at
Twitter he's at Google now maybe he made
this blog post about building
recommendation systems off of what
people tweet right so they look at
Foursquare check-ins by people tweeting
like
or they do TV show recommendations by
people tweeting I'm watching this show
right now and it's all goes in scalding
it's very it's pretty clear it's got
some some convincing results reading a
blog post.really about me like kind of
realized the power of this stuff and
then the source code is there's so many
undocumented features in the source code
you kind of have to dig in a little bit
but there's a lot of gold nuggets in
there for sure so we're going to use
this to start filtering signals and
we're going to do it by thinking about
matrices instead of streams of data or
things like that and so if we take this
is our input data right just noisy green
line time is going down I guess and so
when we're doing these fi our filters
what we're doing is we're taking it
we're aligning it at the very top and
you know multiplying the coefficients by
the data value summing them up that's
the output then we go to the next place
we do the same thing over and over and
what we're doing really is a dot product
of these coefficients and the input
values and I put a little X over the
half just to say that every time we do
this the output Y is using the same
filter but it's using a different slice
of the input right the X hat is totally
made up simple so we can figure this
another way which is instead of taking a
different piece of the data and we can
make this filter just expand it out by
adding a bunch of zeros and doing a dot
product of the whole thing the result
will be the same because all those
zeroes will just make you know the
multiplication will be zero they won't
have to
some so we're doing the same thing but
in this case we're instead of sliding
the filter through the data were kind of
a rather I guess letting the data and
keeping the same filter we're modifying
the filter keeping the same data so i
move the hat but what this not only is
doing really is we're taking a input
vector multiplying it by a whole bunch
of other vectors and then aligning the
results that's just 0 this is Rho vector
multiplying that's matrix of filters
right so the red part is the filter
that's moving through as you do these
matrix multiplications you're really
just applying it over and over and over
sticking the output value you know in
its correct place just working for
everybody so far girl with me all right
crowd so this is for one operation right
what we've just done is added a whole
lot of overhead we're multiplying tons
and tons of zeros it's kind of annoying
why do we have matrices we could just
use a filter function but now we can add
as many of these inputs as we want
during that from a set of the vector to
an input matrix multiply that by the
filter matrix and what will get out is
another matrix the same size as the
input of all of these filters signals so
in this case I've got n blogs like I've
got 140 million blogs no reason I
couldn't do it that way
but it's going to be pretty big and so
this is some our code to basically do
that locally right it's very small I
take I make a matrix of four signals you
can see X 1 2 3 and 4 this is how you
construct a square wave it's the sign of
one hurts plus one third design of three
hurts those one-fifth 5 hurts all the
way to infinity I just have a little
pieces of here so X 4 here i'm saying is
going to be a square wave will take that
data frame turn it into matrix and then
we build a filter i use this function
called topless topless matrix is
something like this where each each row
is like a shifted version of the one
next to it this is I realize now this is
sort of special case the our chocolates
won't you don't use it because you can
read about it on wikipedia but they
repeat not only on Roosevelt's colonies
on my github with stuff about this talk
i have a function in Julia that will
build the right metrics either way you
build your your filter and then just do
this make this multiplication at the end
and you've done it you've applied your
your filter four times and so this is
what those inputs look like right the
first one is just a sine wave the next
one has a higher frequency and a smaller
amplitude the next one was even higher
and even smaller attitude and then the
sum looks kind of square right it's
fairly flat on top it's fairly steep in
the middle
on the transitions we apply that filter
and you get this as an output it's a
low-pass filter that we're applying in
this case so the lowest frequencies
stayed pretty pretty well the next one
down was attenuated some the higher
frequency still is continuing to even
more an interesting thing to look at is
the result of the bottom we've turned
our square dish signal into a mound if
signal and when you're working with
digital signals a lot of times square
wave it's used it's like a clock right
you need to perform an action every time
this thing arises there are a lot of
triggers that you can set in digital
hardware and so the time that this thing
takes to rise is very important because
it's not a zero it's not a one it's like
somewhere in between and you want that
to transition very quickly in order to
get a good timing on your I don't know
sampling
picture whatever it is that it's doing
every time that thing rises in like
actual hardware so what we did by
filtering this is those black lines are
the same width apart low i hope everyone
and see it we've expanded how long it
takes actually rise it has the same kind
of overall frequency but that's that's
the main change that we made to it here
that's that this is a pretty good way of
actually visualizing like how the
different components were effective and
things like that so we're going to do
this in scalding which has a matrix
library which is super convenient for us
it stores data a sparse representation
of the data so it doesn't store like an
enormous square square matrix it stores
a pipe like we're seeing earlier with
three fields in it the row ID column ID
and then the value that exists there
awesome for sparse matrices because you
don't have to represent a ton of zeros
it assumes that if something's missing
it's got the value zero and that's what
we're going to be working with because
you saw ankles mostly zeros some of the
stuff they have built in a bunch of norm
operations you can do when converting
matrix which is awesome add multiply
subtract things like that someone I
think it's people at Etsy or working on
QR factorization if you like really want
to go crazy on I'm going to make your
season stuff they're also doing there's
a lot of work going into doing SPD's or
at least partial SPD's and that link
will bring you to more information up I
guess but it's only played with a little
bit enough to kind of do this and a few
other things but the matrix library is
pretty great it's not as good as just
working in MATLAB or something like that
but you you know the idea is to scale
and we're going to use this on our side
there's one hundred and hundred forty
million nodes three and a half billion
edges or an edge is you know if I follow
you that's
it's a directed edge from me to you that
appeared at a certain time stamps these
the three columns we have we were in
calculate first number of followers per
day for every single blog apply of
moving average to all of it and so here
is the code to do that so most of the
code is really just generating this
follows matrix right take input data in
this case we're only filtering out the
last we only want one year because I'm a
you know women I guess um we're turning
those actual time stamps into dates so
that we can do this per day then
grouping by the blog ID that's receiving
the follow receiving the edge and day
and so that size will give us falls per
day for every single blog there's gonna
be a lot of zeros I've got like eight
blogs and none of them got any followers
today so that's eight zeros in the sense
oh and then there's just a 2 matrix
function you tell it that the ID is a
date or they date is a string the ID is
an integer and then the number of
follows is a double and then we've got
this Copeland's function again this is
one I had to write that builds a pipe
with the filter as it's aligned
perfectly the input is the actual filter
you want and then the number of rows and
columns that it's going to be
we'll build it for you and then you just
take your follows multiply it by the
filter take the transpose of that and
you've got your results so I mean that
line 14 right there is doing all of the
filtering for us all of all the stuff on
you know hundreds of gigabytes in this
case but it could very well be more it's
it's pretty awesome to think about so
once we do that we've got a bunch of
smooth signal supposedly I'll show you
in a second we won't actually do
something with it right just filtering
some stuff doesn't I don't know it's
just still a bunch of data and I Purdue
cluster it's not getting us anywhere so
we want to find blogs who have
accelerating follower counts right so if
today i have 100 followers and I gained
one that's the derivative of that so the
velocity is one and if tomorrow I get to
then that means it's positive
acceleration the next day i get 3 and
it's more positive acceleration if there
that i get to its come down right so
that's the end what I want is to find a
blog who is just exploding like getting
more followers than the previous day for
the longest time and so I grabbed a
couple of blogs and when I did this and
so these are just sort of three examples
I couldn't put the names of the blog
because we don't talk about we don't
publicize follower counts the way
Twitter and a lot of weather
will do there are some pretty good
reasons for it around like follower
trend and perceived reputation you just
want people to like do good stuff
whether they have five or 5,000
followers so anyway the first one is
actually an advertiser those big spikes
when they run ads they get huge you know
hun thousands of followers a day blog be
is this sort of meme blog that blew up
was really popular for a little while
and then died down but apparently didn't
die down as much as I thought it did and
blog see is it's one of the more popular
kind of trends on tumblr it's like
trying to think of somebody follow the
DevOps reaction as well have you heard
of this so it's that right it's like you
know a house burning down and it's like
when I'm on call and like everything's
awful so the blog that really started
this sort of mean that got coffee
everywhere was super popular was on The
Today Show I think or something so
that's them right and so what I did was
I looked at these are the number of you
followers per day so the actual y value
is the velocity what I want to see is if
the value today is higher than the value
yesterday if it is then it's going to be
blue if the valley today's lesson number
of new followers today is fewer than
yesterday you're still gaining followers
then it's right so we want to find the
largest streak of blue
basically but you can very clearly see
especially in the bottom model to focus
on that more there's the weekly
variation that I was talking about
earlier it's crystal clear like fruity
so we applied the filters all of using
they got this which is a lot better
right see it's a very clear continuous
acceleration of Block C even though
there's at weekly variation we've now
gotten rid of the other ones do a little
bit better you can see blog be in the
beginning years
variation blah gaze is extremely spicy
so it's filter doesn't do a whole lot
for us the thing is is that there's one
little red dot and all of this
continuously increasing thing and that
sucks right because we want to see the
largest blue piece we can this one guy
is going to ruin it right this thing
might be several weeks this guy comes in
knocks it out and now if we just blindly
say who's going to longest they're going
to get sort of cut off so this is by the
way so this is the output of the filter
I was talking about right just just
doing this 140 million times it's pretty
impressive to me maybe to you so we're
going to do this we're going to take the
filtered values and we're going to make
this new type of signal out of it and
it's going to be a binary signal it's if
that thing was blue if they've got more
followers today and they did yesterday
then this value was a big one otherwise
it's going to be zero and we're going to
take that binary signal we're going to
run it through yet another filter and so
what we'll get out of that is a value
we're between zero and one right if
you've got seven consecutive days where
you do not have more followers in the
previous day that filtered result will
be 0 if you have seven good solid days
in a row and the filter was odd will be
one and so it should be somewhere in
between most of the time though because
it's going to be alternating back and
forth between 0 and 1 so this will take
this binary signal running a filter
through it will convert it to another
continuous signal somewhere between
point 7 5 0 and 1 and we're going to
take anything above on 75 so this is
sort of what it looks like the bottom
looking at the bottom one again the
points on the top are where you've got
more followers today than yesterday the
ones on the bottom or where you didn't
and so that one point right there is the
thing that would have screwed us up but
now we've gotten past it this blog once
all filtered they actually were
accelerating the follower count for 48
days straight that's unheard of I think
I so I sort of hand-picked a few of
these two look out up close like I can't
believe that if anybody has gotten that
many
new Twitter followers every day for 40
days let me know because that's a month
on half the other ones did pretty good
right before they were they were much
fewer continuous days of growth but even
36 days is crazy 15 days is a lot of
acceleration so this is the sort of
thing that we can apply this and go and
not like we really want to see if we
missed anything like maybe there was
really popular blog event like teenagers
in Brazil knew about and we missed we
can find them this way we can pick them
up we can remove all the noise and
really know what is going on and I think
this is one great application there's so
many more page views against with
whatever it is if you want and to do it
at scale is really really exciting for
us that's my top I hope you guys got
something out of it
any question I was that clear
yes why are you scolding and the matrix
is it a year to become deeper
so that
yeah so but once I happened it won't
matter
more
it's so I've read through the code a
little bit and I believe what it's doing
is it it figures out you witch oh sorry
the question was sort of more about the
the matrix multiplication in scalding
and what it's actually doing under the
hood really in terms of mapping and
reducing so believe what it does is it
goes through it and uses the 30 column
values and it figures out which things
need to be multiplied together and then
we'll group by tho those new IDs and
then multiply the things or add or
whatever it is you're doing the things
in that group and maybe it'll have two
groups where the first group and
multiply than your group again and some
effector I'm not like absolutely
positively nothing but I mean if I was
just trying to write that that's where I
would start on the other thing is it to
know how many reducers it uses you have
to give it some amount of information
doesn't know how big this matrix is so
if we'll there are different types of
ways you tell it to guess you can tell
it give it basically a sparsity
percentage say like one percent of this
matrix has value
and we'll make a decision based on that
and the other thing is you can tell how
many rows and columns you expect it to
have and we'll make a guess based on
that and it's the worst that the matrix
stuff is not super documented especially
you know tuning these types of things
for like how many introduces views and
whatnot so you're gonna have to dig
through some code but it's fairly clean
there's a lot of magic in the scalding
code if anybody's r in scala and loves
implicit and likes to just have things
take care for them there's a ton of that
they love that that's where I guess but
once you kind of get a handle on that
and see what's going on it's very
forward
I'm sorry
minutes tens of minutes probably less
than an hour yeah but I think we could
probably turn it up too like I was
saying little more reduces you use the
better to a point so we probably tune
it's running faster
we've got about a hundred machines with
I think 16 cores each our cluster is
relatively small in that way but there's
a lot of its I don't know it's more
storage based on computation based I
guess it's several petabytes out of just
different machines which I hear is
pretty pretty heavy it's written in yeah
it's already installed so I mean they
don't use any of the like like way part
or any of it like old there is any of
that and the big thing is that if you
think about your running this on a
distributed system there's 100 machines
there's duplicated data there you know I
guess we do this design so it could be
in different data centers but it
shouldn't be but i mean the the main
performance it is going to be in
shuffling data around and aligning it
performing the multiplications quickly
is not at all of your biggest concern
how do we come up with a definition
trending blog um I mean most of our
turning content is sort of like you know
I'd love together someone to people talk
about that we don't use this for
trending blog most heartrending stuff is
just sort of like we look at the
expected number of likes or reblogs or
whatever or intranet tags the expected
number of times that would be used and
if it's like a huge outlier above that
then sort of like z-score I guess take
the mean divided by the the difference
from the mean divided by the variance
disease for and then just sort those we
used some version of that for the
trending stuff it's really modified I
don't clear they don't know a lot about
it but that's all
the training stuff is all are trending
tags or actually kind of in real time we
consume our own fire buns and calculate
it that way trending blogs like this
would be done daily so we don't actually
use this for like trending content stuff
because it's too slow but
is there a little backup ado cluster
yeah
if you have another a different monster
there's a function called disc copy that
comes with a Duke yeah I don't I stay
away from the main next part where we do
cluster as much as I can
alright well thank you guys